les médias ils en ont soupé s'ils
reviennent aujourd'hui c'est mû par le
besoin de dire leur vérité au nom de
celle qui ne peut plus parler
je sais par contre c'est notre vraie vie
bonjour comment vit-on avec le mensonge
de alexia notre fille est un récit à la
première personne le double jeu
d'isabelle et jean-pierre face au double
jeu du meurtrier de leur fille de voix
pour quatre années de cauchemar et pied
critiqué jugés accusés même d'avoir
comploté en famille les gens ils peuvent
raconter ce qu'ils veulent nous on sait
qui on est moi tu es mon tempérament
malheureusement ce partenaire nippon
comment on fait quand on sait qu'on est
innocent et qu'on entend des horreurs à
répétition sur hull à médias sur un
journal alors oui ces livres c'est pour
montrer vraiment qui on est et qui est
alexia carr la sphère d'aval a écrasé sa
victime johnatan le veuf éploré l'homme
le plus haï de france de l'aveu même de
ses avocats a pris toute la place il
était le gendre trop parfait le presque
fisc les parents de la victime ont porté
à bout de bras défendu bec et ongles
jusqu'au premier aveu trois longs mois
de trahison quotidienne
la première supportrice l'oxygène
comment avez vous pu être dupées à ce
point
on dit que l'amour rend aveugle mais
fait exactement ce qui nous est arrivé à
tous les deux vous l'aimiez va bien sûr
on va pas le renier c'est pour ça que je
n'ai jamais ya eu aucun doute on s'est
même jamais imaginé que ce soit lui oui
hommage appuyé aux gendarmes et à la
justice le livre règle aussi quelques
comptes déferlement médiatique
belle-famille indifférente avocat sans
scrupules défense assassines et
frustration pour les parents d'alexia la
quête de vérité ne s'est pas arrêtée
avec le procès
il était condamné pour sa dernière
version mais la vérité qu'on a nous ne
va pas on n'a pas la vérité n'a pas
reconnu qu'il l'a droguée il ya la
préméditation qui est de parler
médicament ne peut pas l'ouvrir mais on
peut pas le prouver vous écrivez dans ce
livre notre vie d'une parenthèse 1
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas je sais
qu'on doit continuer de vivre
pour stéphanie grigori
pour nos deux petits enfants justement
comme disait jean pierre ils ont besoin
de nous
c'est pour ça que ce livre
c'est pour leur laisser un témoignage
ils seront quelle est la vérité c'est le
plus dur c'est de survivre à alexia
c'est ça c'est
dû penser tous les jours et
il s'en rapprocher tous les jours un
livre parce que les écrits restent et
parce qu'il ne voulait pas qu'elle se
taise